y
[Música]
continúa el asedio ruso sobre la ciudad
portuaria de mariupol la planta de acex
tal sigue siendo el último bastión de
las fuerzas ucranianas donde las
autoridades aseguran que también hay
muchos civiles desde eeuu aseguran que
los socios de ucrania han proporcionado
más equipamiento militar
la agencia de naciones unidas para los
refugiados anunció el número de
ucranianos que han huido al extranjero
desde el inicio de la guerra ha superado
los 5 millones y 7,1 millones de
personas se desplazaron dentro del país
en total más de 12 millones abandonaron
sus hogares
manuel macro ni marín le pen se
enfrentan este miércoles en el esperado
debate presidencial de cara a las
elecciones del próximo domingo en esta
emisión echaremos un vistazo al detrás
de la escena del encuentro y conoceremos
cómo fue preparado
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos este informativo
en ucrania y nos enfocamos en la ciudad
de mariupol que sigue asediada por las
tropas rusas en el día 56 de la invasión
la inmensa planta siderúrgica de hace
hostal sigue siendo el último bastión de
las fuerzas ucranianas donde también se
refugian civiles rusia dio un nuevo
ultimátum a las tropas de ucrania que
siguen sin rendirse por el momento y se
anunció un acuerdo preliminar para la
apertura de corredores que faciliten la
evacuación de unos 6000 civiles el
asesor de la presidencia ucraniana instó
a todos los ciudadanos a que utilicen
esos corredores al máximo entretanto la
ofensiva se intensifica en el este del
país en donde los bombardeos han
impactado varias zonas residenciales el
ejército ucraniano pide cada vez más
asistencia militar para resistir los
ataques veamos el siguiente informe
la planta de acero a sos tal en la
ciudad portuaria de mariupol bajo el
constante asalto de las fuerzas rusas es
el ultimo bolsón de resistencia
ucraniana en la ciudad desde hace días
los combates ucranianos se han
atrincherado allí
y según las autoridades también miles de
civiles refugiados bajo la fábrica los
soldados asediados escasos de alimentos
lanzaron un llamado desesperado en las
redes sociales para pedir ayuda nosotros
nos enfrentamos quizás a nuestros
últimos días sino horas el enemigo nos
superan en número diez a uno muy
disfrutamos
apelamos y suplicamos a todos los
líderes mundiales que nos ayuden les
pedimos que utilicen el procedimiento de
extracción y nos lleven a territorio de
un tercer estado pero todo el 'trader'
dragón el presidente ucraniano dice que
su petición a rusia de una evacuación no
ha sido atendida lamentablemente no
hemos tenido ninguna respuesta de rusia
a la oferta de intercambio que podría
salvar a los civiles y defensores de
mariupol y este silencio debe ser notado
por todos los que han estado pueden
estar asociados con rusia rusia ha
intensificado sus ataques en todo el
frente del este en su punto de mira
ciudades como es lo bians trama torch
con esta ofensiva rusia afirma haber
entrado en una nueva fase de guerra
el ejército ruso está llevando a cabo
las tareas establecidas por el jefe del
ejército para la operación militar
especial se están aplicando el plan de
liberación de las repúblicas populares
de donges y lugar así como las medidas
para restablecer la paz
mr rusia sigue lanzando asaltos contra
las demás ciudades asediadas en kharkiv
al menos cuatro personas murieron el
martes en bombardeos contra zonas
residenciales
como veníamos avanzando rusia prosigue
su avance sobre el este de ucrania el
asesor de la presidencia ucraniana
confirmó que las tropas rusas concentran
sus esfuerzos en la ciudad de hume en el
noreste en dirección a la cercana
slomianski según el funcionario rusia
habría iniciado también el asalto sobre
roubini y popas ni en la región de
lugansk por el momento afirman desde
ucrania han conseguido frenar los
ataques de moscú que por el momento
también no ha difundido reportes de la
situación
y desde estados unidos llegan
declaraciones del portavoz del pentágono
john kirby quien ha afirmado que los
socios de ucrania le han proporcionado
más aviones militares y piezas para
reparar otros del arsenal de kiev que
estaban dañados o no eran operativos
me gustaría decir sin entrar en lo que
otras naciones están proporcionando que
ellos han recibido plataformas y piezas
adicionales para poder aumentar el
tamaño de su flota el tamaño de su flota
de aviones creo que lo dejaría así para
fans en plataformas y partes una
plataforma es un avión en este caso han
recibido aviones adicionales y partes de
aviones para ayudarlos a poner más
aviones en el aire
diría que ciertamente hemos ayudado con
el transbordo de algunas piezas de
repuesto adicionales que han ayudado con
las necesidades de sus aviones pero no
hemos transportado aviones completos
entretanto las negociaciones de paz
siguen estancadas este miércoles el
portavoz del kremlin dmitri peskov acusó
a ucrania de incumplir los compromisos
adquiridos durante las conversaciones de
paz y aseguró que esto está ralentizando
el ritmo de las conversaciones todo ello
luego que el negociador principal de
ucrania dijera al martes que era difícil
predecir cuándo podrían reanudarse las
conversaciones ahora la pelota está del
lado de ucrania aseguró peskov
cuando la parte ucraniana retrocede
permanentemente en sus compromisos y
palabras anteriores los cambia
constantemente esto está teniendo
consecuencias nefastas para la
eficiencia de las conversaciones ahora
hemos transmitido a la parte ucraniana
nuestro borrador de un documento que
contiene una redacción clara la pelota
está de su lado y estamos esperando su
respuesta
la agencia de las naciones unidas para
los refugiados anunció que el número de
personas ucranianas que han huido al
extranjero desde el inicio de la guerra
ha superado ya los 5 millones en las
últimas 24 horas han salido otras 20.000
personas del país y polonia ha recibido
a 28 millones de todos estos refugiados
además allá hay 71 millones de
desplazados internos y de esta manera
son ya más de 12 millones los ucranianos
que dejaron sus hogares desde el inicio
de la invasión el 24 de febrero
el número de refugiados que huyen a
través de las fronteras sigue aumentando
a diario entonces en menos de dos meses
en unas ocho semanas hemos visto a la
cuarta parte de la población de ucrania
más de 12 millones de personas en total
incluidos 5 millones de refugiados pero
también alrededor de 75 millones de
personas dentro del país que se han
visto obligadas a huir de sus hogares
entonces esta es una cantidad asombrosa
de personas que tuvieron que dejar sus
hogares sus posesiones en algunos casos
miembros de la familia atrás millones de
vidas han sido destrozadas y sus vidas
destrozadas por esta guerra
seguimos en europa con otras noticias
relevantes de la jornada en reino unido
el juez paul goal spring de la corte de
magistrados de westminster remitió y
miércoles a la ministra británica del
interior principal la orden de
extradición a eeuu del fundador de
wikileaks julian assange
patel tendrá un plazo de 2 meses
prorrogable para decidir si confirma o
desestima la entrega mientras que la
defensa del australiano ya ha indicado
que rebatir a ésta el pasado 14 de marzo
el tribunal supremo el más alto del
reino unido- dio luz verde a la
extradición de assange al rechazar un
recurso que buscaba impedir la kristinn
hrafnsson editor en jefe de wikileaks
aseguró que el tribunal está encaminado
está encaminando a assange hacia la pena
de muerte
y nos vamos a españa porque allí se vive
este miércoles el primer día tras el
decreto del fin del uso obligatorio del
tapabocas en interiores salvo en algunos
casos específicos como los hospitales o
el transporte público la medida ha sido
acogida con cautela y por el momento no
todo el mundo se atreve a dejar de usar
la mascarilla nuestra corresponsal en
madrid marina colorado nos cuenta más
desde la principal estación de trenes de
la capital española
setecientos días después de su
imposición el uso de las mascarillas en
interiores en españa' ya no es
obligatorio la medida tiene excepciones
como por ejemplo dentro de centros y
servicios sanitarios y también dentro
del transporte público no así en las
estaciones como por ejemplo en esta de
atocha en el centro de la capital
española eso sí la mayoría de las
personas continúan llevando la la
noticia no ha sido recibida de la misma
manera por la ciudadanía sobre todo con
una diferencia de respuesta según las
edades pues yo lo veo bien la verdad
creo que ahora la pandemia ya está más
controlada y la verdad que creo que es
una medida que es positiva se supone que
se hace lo de acabar con las mascarillas
porque la situación epidemiológica ha
mejorado pero también es verdad que hay
gente que es más vulnerable o que tiene
inmunodeficiencia o que tiene algún
problema alguna patología y por lo tanto
pues entiendo que esa gente se proteja
con la mascarilla que es hasta ahora la
medida que tiene a mano en los comercios
o en los lugares de trabajo dependerá de
cada empresa a decidir si es obligatorio
o no y lo tendrán que decidir después de
hacer una evaluación
el riesgo laboral que suponga el no
llevar la mascarilla para los empleados
hemos preguntado a varios de ellos y la
mayoría dice que seguirá llevando la
mascarilla aunque muchos de ellos decían
que su empresa no les ha dicho si
todavía sigue siendo obligatoria algunos
de ellos o la mayoría lo hacen por
seguridad personal
en la empresa es opcional nos han dado a
elegir si preferimos llevarla o no
llevarla
más que nada por precaución si una
persona con problemas respiratorios y de
momento
el fin de las mascarillas en interiores
es un paso más en la estrategia del
gobierno español frente a la convivencia
con el hobbit 19 un paso que dependerá
en gran medida de decisiones personales
y de cambios de costumbres tras 2 años
incorporando el tapabocas como elemento
esencial de nuestra rutina en un nuevo
desarrollo que podría reforzar la ya
manifiesta irritación de rusia el
parlamento finlandés el eduskunta empezó
hoy la discusión sobre su eventual
solicitud de ingreso a la otan con la
invasión rusa ucrania la opinión pública
de este país neutral hasta ahora dio un
giro total y ahora la mayoría apoya a
unirse a la alianza atlántica rusia que
comparte una frontera de mil 340
kilómetros con finlandia ha reaccionado
a la posibilidad amenazando desplegar
armas nucleares en su ex enclave de
kaliningrado y otras medidas la decisión
del parlamento se espera para antes de
la cumbre de la otan en madrid el
próximo junio
sigue la tensión en el pacífico por el
pacto de seguridad que china anunció
haber firmado con el gobierno de las
islas salomón el primer ministro de la
pequeña nación manasés socavar e afirmó
en el parlamento que el acuerdo no
afectará la paz en la región por su
parte scott morrison primer ministro de
australia enfatizó la preocupación de su
país y sus aliados por el acuerdo y
denunció presiones de china a otras
naciones de la región
australia eeuu y reino unido tienen el
llamado pacto a hocus para proveer al
primero de submarinos nucleares y otras
capacidades militares pacto que ha sido
duramente criticado por china
las islas solomon no tienen ningún
adversario externo y el marco está
dirigido a ningún país o alianzas
externas sino a nuestra propia situación
de seguridad interna del estado
complementa nuestro acuerdo de seguridad
de 2017 con australia web
este es un tema en curso y se está
ejerciendo mucha presión sobre otros
países del pacífico de nuestra red y lo
que tienen que entender es que voy a
trabajar con ellos no voy a actuar como
las administraciones anteriores que
trataban al pacífico como una extensión
de australia las islas del pacífico son
muy sensibles a eso
hoy es el día en el que se enfrentan en
manuel macro ni marine lepén en el tan
esperado debate previo a la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
del domingo los últimos sondeos muestran
que el presidente francés y aspirante a
la reelección aventaja a la candidata de
extrema derecha sin embargo el índice de
votantes indecisos se mantiene alto
este es el plato donde se celebrará el
debate presidencial francés para este
crucial cara a cara todo ha sido
acordado de antemano por las dos
campañas atrás queda la gran mesa que
compartieron de manuel macro imagen del
pen durante el debate de 2017 en su
lugar dos mesas más pequeñas una para
cada candidato separadas por dos metros
y medio los dos periodistas que moderan
estarán sentados juntos a cuatro metros
de distancia si te dice mundo interno es
muy diferente una entrevista es
realmente un trabajo un papel de
moderador para túnel y esquivan terius
de chicago no es un periodista que
quiere entrevistar la prioridad es
necesario siete y diez mil y ti pero
tendrá el debate un impacto en los
votantes
[Música]
no he hecho mi elección espero muchas
cosas espero detalles de los dos
candidatos
no cambiará mi decisión no veré más que
nada porque tengo curiosidad no para
decidirme realmente
no creo que lo vea porque no espero
mucho son dos candidatos que no me
gustan nada
para garantizar la imparcialidad los
candidatos han sorteado el lugar en el
que se sentarán en el plato y quien
hablará primero ma yinglin estará a la
derecha y comenzará al debate también se
ha acordado la temperatura del estudio
19 grados centígrados para evitar el
sudor indirecto se utilizarán 16 cámaras
para filmar el encuentro en 2017 16
millones y medio de franceses siguieron
el debate la cifra de audiencia más baja
desde 1974 locas sipse y los invito a
que hoy sintonicen france 24 a las 14
horas de ciudad de méxico bogotá quito y
lima ya que tenemos una transmisión
especial con el debate presidencial en
francia presentado por maría clara calle
y con el análisis de expertos invitados
con esto acabamos este informativo sigan
conectados a france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]